[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je m'appelle david malm ans je
suis éditeur et donc je vais vous parler
d'héritage immatériel il ya quelques
années avec des amis j'ai créé une
maison d'édition et comme je n'ai pas du
tout de l'édition j'ai fait ce qu'il
faut toujours faire quand on arrive dans
une maison on est un invité
je suis allé voir des libraires et des
éditeurs et des éditrices pour leur
demander ce que c'était que l'édition et
le livre est le mot qui revenait le plus
souvent quand on présentait le métier
d'éditeur
on me disait vous voyez fondamentalement
en fait moi je ne suis rien d'autre
qu'un passeur et j'ai entendu en fait je
pense 80 fois ce terme de passeurs alors
petit anecdote personnelle moi le terme
de passeurs quand je l'entends il fait
toujours frémir
ce que j'imagine un marais au 12e siècle
une barque qui traverse le marais
quelqu'un dans capitonné qui tend sa
main pour récupérer une piécette en
échange de cette pièce est me fera
passer de l'autre côté sain et sauf
bien sûr c'est pas image la plus glamour
qu'on peut avoir pour décrire un métier
mais je me suis dit bon c'est dans ma
tête voilà mais quand même le mot de
passe hommes jeunes et aussi pour une
autre raison c'est que voyez l'image que
dont je vous parlais de ce passeur cette
barque qui va d'une rive à l'autre ça
évoque cette idée que cette idée
d'intégrité de transmission de
conservation or l'édition le livre la
librairie
ce n'est pas du tout ça au sens où on
parle d' héritage immatériel et
l'héritage quand il est immatériel il
n'a pas la même résistance la même
solidité que le reste du réel il ya une
définition du réel que j'aime beaucoup
qui aiderait définition de philip k dick
qui disait le réel c'est ce qui se
refuse à disparaître quand on cesse d'y
croire or les héritages du matériel cd
héritage ou quand on cesse d'y croire
ils ont tendance à se déliter
fondamentalement c'est d'héritage qui
demandent du travail de notre part ce
bâtiment
l'église une cathédrale une école quand
on part du bâtiment n'ont pas besoin de
notre soins permanents pour demeurer et
traversé les âges les héritage
immatériel
al'inverse pour qu'on puisse les
transmettre il faut qu'on se les
approprient et on les transforme à
chaque fois en fait ce que je voudrais
ce soir en vous parlant du rôle de
l'édition dans les héritage immatériel
c'est à vous faire voir que on a
l'illusion d'une permanence de la
culture alors qu'en fait il faut avoir
la certitude de sa transformation
permanente est en fait que vous voyez
que vous vouliez ou non transformé la
culture vous l'a transformé donc autant
être conscients de l'effet que vous avez
sur la culture de manière à un peu
dirigé cet effet alors pour vous faire
mieux voir ce que ce dont je parle quand
je parle de transformation d'héritage
immatériel au sein de l'édition je vais
vous donner un exemple très simple
une transformation qui a cours sous vos
yeux actuellement dont vous n'êtes
peut-être pas complètement conscient
c'est le retour de la littérature
allégorique
alors si vous allez dans une librairie
vous verrez il n'y a aucun rayon qui
s'appelle littérature allégorique
c'est un terme qui existent mais très
peu de gens l'emploi tout simplement
parce que c'est un terme qui a plus de
150 ans et en fait il ya 150 ans il y
avait beaucoup moins de livres publiés
beaucoup moins de lecteurs
et donc on n'avait pas besoin de
segmenter les librairies les quelques
librairies par faye ont comme ça et donc
d'inventer ce rayon aujourd'hui les
rayons principalement ses littérature
générale littérature de genre et au sein
des littératures de gens vous avez le
polar la fantaisie la science fiction
la romance la romance érotique j'allais
commencé à improviser d'autres genres
mais comme il est peut-être dans la
salle des gens qui sont qu'au moins de
18 ans ce n'est pas une très bonne idée
donc il ya plein de gens voilà
aujourd'hui on a littérature générale et
les littératures de genre mais ya 150
ans on n'avait pas cette distinction est
une grande partie de la littérature
était pensé comme une littérature
allégorique donc pour comprendre le
changement qui
à l'oeuvre et dont je vous parle d'une
sorte de grand come back
je vous propose de revenir presque 200
ans en arrière il ya 200 ans
il n'y a pas de distinction dans la
littérature entre la littérature
générale et la littérature de change
cette distinction c'est une distinction
qui est construite et que nous avons
construites au 19e siècle
et deuxième chose sur cet événement il
ya 200 ans
c'est qu'il ya 200 ans le roman qui est
le best-seller de l'époque c'est le
frankenstein de mary shelley
c'est le premier roman d'une jeune
anglaise et c'est une sorte de deux
collections d'allégories extrêmement
étendue ce qui est intéressant c'est que
à chaque époque chaque génération va se
réapproprier frankenstein et faire
saillir une des allégories frankenstein
c'est par exemple une des allégories de
frankenstein qui nous est moins
perceptible aujourd'hui c'est que
frankenstein c'est une allégorie de la
révolution française au sens où les
anglais un peu comment dire qu on
placerait à gauche aujourd'hui voilà ont
trouvé ça super la révolution française
jusqu'au jour où ils ont compris que les
citoyens britanniques n'étaient pas les
bienvenus en france parce qu'ils étaient
perçus comme peut-être des agents la
contre-révolution donc frankenstein
c'est une création fantastique qui
échappent à ces créateurs qui détruit
tout comme la révolution française je
dis pas que c'est ce que je pense c'est
pas du tout ce que je pense c'est ce que
pensait toute cette génération de
romantique britannique autres matrice
autres allégorique il ya dans ce
frankenstein frankenstein c'est la
preuve que les femmes peuvent enfanter
c'est à dire faire des enfants mais que
les hommes peuvent concevoir des enfants
mais les enfants tu pas le jour où un
homme veut créer un autre être humain il
bricole quelque chose et c'est un
monstre
c'était très féministe finalement
c'était réglé ses comptes avec son mari
c'était oui c'était très allez bo a
élaboré comme manière de régler ses
comptes mais ça a bien marché puisque
maintenant on s'en souvient encore
la troisième à ligori que je trouve
enfin il y en a plein d'autres mais une
sur lesquels je voudrais attirer votre
attention
c'est que fondamentalement dans
frankenstein
il ya cette idée de faire passer toute
une série d'idées à partir d'une
métaphore à partir d'un récit qui est
imaginaire donc aujourd'hui frankenstein
s'est classé en littérature générale
aujourd'hui ça serait en littératures de
l'imaginaire parce que en fait à
l'époque la grande angoisse des
écrivains romantiques c'est que le début
du 19ème siècle c'est une époque où il
va y avoir de plus en plus pour des
raisons techniques de moyens de faire
des livres d'imprimer des livres et il
va y avoir de plus en plus de lecteurs
et les écrivains romantiques c'est les
premiers écrivains qui ne savent pas par
qu'ils vont être plus quant au lycée
vous étudiez des auteurs du xviie au
xviiie siècle
ils ont à peu près tous une connaissance
plus ou moins précise de qui va les lire
quand vous êtes au xixème siècle vous ne
savez plus qui vous lit parce que tout
simplement les gens sont trop nombreux
et très vite apparaît un problème ce
neuvième siècle
si vous avez plein de lecteurs mais
c'est une génération nouvelle d'hommes
et de femmes qui n'est pas très cultivé
ils savent lire mais n'ont pas de
culture littéraire est en fait tout
allégorie toute image tout métaphore
toute allusion culturelle est une forme
de droit de péage qui leur empêche en
fait de rentrer dans le livre est donc
il ya toute une autre génération
décrivant après mary shelley qui va
avoir un double raisonnement
raisonnement politique et un
raisonnement
comment dire économique c'est si je veux
être lui il faut que je sois lisible si
je veux être lisible je ne peux plus
passer par une culture littéraire que
non pas mes lecteurs et l'autre chose
aussi c'est que politiquement ces
problématiques de fait de faire une
littérature qui une littérature qui
s'adresse finalement à une sorte d'élite
alors qu'en fait on est dans un
mouvement démocratique où il faut écrire
pour tout le monde et c'est là
qu'apparaît la littérature réaliste dont
vous connaissez peut-être un avatar
plutôt français qui est la littérature
naturaliste et s'ouvre à partir de ce
moment là dans les années 1850 1890 une
domination au sein de la littérature de
la littérature naturaliste et la
littérature de genre en fait et rejetés
vers les marges comme étant une
littérature qui est désuète qui n'est
pas démocratique et où une littérature
de divertissement c'est à dire qu'il ne
part pas du réel finalement ne reste à
la littérature de genre que ce que la
littérature générale ne peut pas faire
c'est à dire très peu de choses à cette
époque là finalement il ya la
structuration parallèle des littératures
de chance c'est à dire c'est la
naissance d'alger wells
l'inventeur de la science fiction et de
william morris qui est l'inventeur de la
fantaisie
revenons à l'époque actuelle à l'époque
actuelle
le film qui a le plus de succès au
cinéma actuellement c'est adventures
c'est ça vous paraît naturel qu'en fait
c'est pas du tout naturel puisque
adventures c'est ce qu'on appelle de la
série b au sens où il ya un certain
temps au cinéma on dépense l'argent pour
faire venir des grandes stars qui
jouaient des histoires d'amour des
histoires historiques en voilà mais pas
des histoires de genre à proprement
parler et la série b c'était les acteurs
de seconde zone qui faisait ce qu'on
appellerait des récits de genre c'est à
dire de la science fiction la fantaisie
de l'horreur du fantastique et ce qui
s'est passé sur les dernières années
c'est qu'il ya eu une inversion la série
a est devenue la série b et la série b
est devenue la série à c'est à dire que
les films ils sont les plus vu les films
sur lesquels on dépense le plus les
films qui sont les plus commentés
des films qui appartiennent à des récits
de genre en fait il ya plusieurs choses
qui se passent de manière concomitante
il ya un phénomène qui est à l'échelle
de nos générations c'est à dire que les
gens qui dans les années 80 les années
90 jouent aux jeux vidéo choix ou show
drôle quand il était enfant il n'avait
pas d'argent qu'ils sont devenus adultes
et qu'on leur a donné des budgets pour
faire des films
ils ont fait des films qui sont aspirés
par le jeu de rôle et par des jeux vidéo
c'est le seigneur des anneaux c'est dans
les années 50-60 c'est un roman et dans
les années 2000 c'est un film à succès
le deuxième phénomène qui est parallèle
et qui est beaucoup plus profond c'est
que en fait le la littérature réaliste
la littérature générale qui était
initialement une littérature tourner
vers le peuple tourné vers la démocratie
si ni tes ratures qui s'est embourgeoisé
c'est à dire de sa puissance
révolutionnaire qui existait au 19e
siècle
c'est une littérature qui est devenue
une littérature vaincu très souvent la
littérature générale
c'est une littérature de consolation qui
vous aide à accepter le monde tel qu'il
est et les littératures de genre ou des
littératures de l'imaginaire vous faut
voir le monde tel qu'il pourrait être
bien sûr c'est beaucoup plus exaltant et
un troisième paramètre qui est un
paramètre mans qui concerne vraiment
cette génération c'est que cette
génération elle est née à la lecture
avec harry potter on se rend pas compte
que à 200 ans d'écart
mary shelley et jk rowling ont changé le
cours de la littérature c'est à dire
comment harry potter est sortie c'était
impossible d'imaginer que ça changerait
complètement l'histoire de la
littérature c'est à dire que quand les
des gens qui sont nés à la lecture grâce
à harry potter arrive à l'âge adulte
il conserve ce goût pour la littérature
de l'imaginaire gagne en appétit pour
les sujets politiques pour le réalisme
ce type de choses mais il conserve cette
intuition fondamental parce qu'on
conserve toujours les intuitions nos
premières expériences de lecteurs ou de
lectrices à tout à l'heure je me
répétais 7 cette phrase et je me suis
rendu compte que quelque chose de très
très dangereux c'est qu'il ya vingt ans
peu moins de 20 ans qui était très à la
mode c'était la tecktonik alors si vous
voyez pas ce que c'est vous allez sur
youtube
et je précise que je vois si je ne suis
pas responsable de tout traumatisme qui
pourraient s'ensuivre de 7 ce passage
sur youtube mais en tout cas j'espère
qu'on sera plus là pour le come back de
la tecktonik mais tout à l'heure je vous
ai mentionné quelqu'un pour vous montrer
en fait l'importance mais ses effets
générationnels et de cet héritage
immatériel
je vous ai dit fin du 19e siècle
création de la littérature générale
domination de la littérature générale
création la science fiction et création
la fantasy avec william morris dans les
années 1950
clément attlee qui était le premier
ministre britannique dans un entretien
c'est un peu l'architecte clément taqlid
l'état providence l'état providence
occidental qu'il a structuré nos états
et nos sociétés pendant très longtemps
et on demande à clément attlee mais d'où
vous sont venus ces idées de maternité
entre les hommes
et sa réponse c'est c'est la lecture de
william morris s'est pas marx c'est lé
roman de william morris william morris
c'est intéressant parce que c'est un
auteur qui était communiste mais qui a
écrit des romans de fantasy
dans ses romans de fantasy il ya des des
brigands qui sont toujours vertueux des
princes qui sont toujours des et
il ya tout un message politique l'idée
de william aurait c'est à dire qu' il
faut faire passer si vous dites
directement aux gens ce que vous pensez
mais en fait vous aurez devant vous que
des gens qui sont déjà d'accord avec
vous si vous mettez sur votre histoire
et sur vos idées à voile d'ignorance et
saissac fait une allégorie
et bien en fait vous à tirer sur vos
textes des gens qui n'avaient pas
nécessairement envie de les lire et vous
les transformez en fait les faits
maurice sur akli ça a été la création de
l'état providence fondamentalement ça
rappelle une phrase qui est d'un certain
shelley mais pas de mary shelley mais de
son époux persie donc en fait d'une
certaine façon c'est monsieur shelley
qui a été un peu éclipsé par pour une
fois par sa femme et
il a une très belle phrase dit les
poètes sont les architectes mais pardon
les architectes méconnu de notre monde
ça veut dire que les poètes au sens de
d'écrivains en général c'est eux qui
structurent notre réel et on s'en rend
pas compte parce que leur action est
très indirecte sauf qu'elle est beaucoup
plus réelle
c'est toute cette idée qui a derrière
les héritage immatériel qu'on transforme
quand je vous dis qu'il ya des éditeurs
par exemple il travaille aujourd'hui au
retour de la littérature allégorique
parce que c'est une façon de prendre en
traître les gens et de pousser la
société dans un sens ou dans un autre
en diffusant des idées mais de manière
masquée en fait à l'issue de cette
petite présentation du retour de la
littérature et allégorique et de comment
mettre en avant la littérature
l'allégorique c'est aussi une manière de
travailler notre héritage immatériel qui
cet héritage fondamentale qui
structurent notre réel je voudrais
simplement que vous partiez avec cette
idée que en fait chaque fois que vous
allez écrire quelque chose que vous
allez choisir un livre que vous allez
offrir un livre vous structurez le réel
de manière extrêmement discrète mais de
manière extrêmement efficace
tout comme william morris a créé l'état
providence moderne
merci
[Applaudissements]